standing health care services across our  valley a new southern nevada health  district clinic it opened today facility  next door to a new early childhood  learning center and across the street  from the library  immunization and family planning  services are available by appointment  city and health leaders say this is much  needed on the east side of town  also i hope it sets a precedent in our  kids minds and our community minds that  taking care of our health is important  by seeing this location here it will be  a constant reminder i need to make sure  i keep taking care of myself before i  can take care of others  in 2022 the services will expand to  include primary hiv and behavioral  health care